un projet pour la réunion est en projet
pour les réunionnais les élus réunis en
séance plénière ont adopté le budget
primitif 2016 1 milliards 180 de 1000
euros avec pour axe essentiel la
solidarité du département aujourd'hui ça
vous s'appuie sur un axe france elle la
solidarité solidarité humaine et
solidarité territoriale solidarité
humaine parce que beaucoup de familles
réunionnaises ont de la souffrance et le
département s'efforce d'apporter de
l'aide à ces familles et on l'a retrouvé
à travers ce budget des sommes quand
même très importants qui vont vers
l'amélioration des situations d'abord il
ya les dépenses obligatoires comme le
rsa la paix après les personnages et les
haines personnes souffrant de handicap
ce sont plus de 1 milliard 300 millions
qui sont consacrés à tout ce qui touche
à l'humain
abreu de lacanau maintenant tapas et
d'investissements de l'ordre de 111
millions d'euros et ses investissements
s'est coincé ce sont des routes des
collèges comme la prison d'un collège à
la plaine des palmistes horizon d'un
collège à saint paul à roquefeuil donc
tous ces travaux ben ce sont des travaux
qui sont engagés par le département en
matière d'éducation en matière de routes
qui profite aux entreprises
réunionnaises écrit permettre de
soutenir l'activité économique de ce
territoire un accès social mais
également un axe économique qui fait la
part belle à nos agriculteurs et l
activité agricole
pour l'élu délégué à l'agriculture la
mise en oeuvre des fonds européens doit
s'accompagner d'un soutien aux
agriculteurs je crois que la présidente
madame nassimah dindar a été
sensibilisée et cette année va être
l'année aussi de la mise en oeuvre des
fonds européens des fonds feader et
c'est pour cette raison que nous
apportons un soutien fort à soutien est
un signal fort en direction du monde
agricole
je crois que c'est un moment attendu par
l'ensemble des professionnels par les
organismes et jeu
nous l'avons confirmé ce matin à travers
le vote du budget un budget que la
présidente du conseil départemental
présente comme un budget offensif et
volontariste 66 % de notre budget son
concert consacré au social au public
vulnérable
il nous reste la marge de manoeuvre pour
se dire quels sont les axes que nous
voulons nous mettre en avant eh bien
nous avons axé sur l'insertion à travers
l'activité économique pour permettre du
développement et le développement du
territoire en prenant compte les hauts
de l'île
en prenant en compte notre richesse au
niveau des forêts au niveau de nos
espaces naturels sensibles mais aussi de
la capacité qu'ont nos agriculteurs à
innover à inventer à produire du bon
produit frais et je pense qu'il faut
aussi continuer à accéder aux aides vers
plus d'agriculteurs pour installer de
nouveaux 300 agriculteurs seront aidés
pour être installé en aidant aussi viry
gassion puisque il n'ya pas
d'agriculture sans eau n'y a pas
d'agriculteurs sans terre il n'y a pas
de l'agriculture s'en est également les
routes et les moyens financiers pour
accompagner préserver la cohésion
sociale tout en développant les secteurs
économiques
deux axes sur lesquels devront s'appuyer
les élus du conseil départemental pour
un développement économique place
l'humain au coeur de ce projet de
mandature